A lazy afternoon in a Hutong - one
of Beijing's traditional residential alleys
in the heart of the city.
This is Backstreet Beijing.
It smells of fresh vegetables, seafood and
pastry.
People here have turned their houses into
small shops and eateries.
For years, these restaurants and kiosks have attracted not only locals but also an international crowd.
But recently, the residents have received unwelcome guests.
Notices like these have spelled the end of
busy shopping and eating alleys.
The government is taking action against building work
that has been done without a proper licence.
And that’s hitting those little shops and
restaurants in the alleys.
Traditionally these houses are open onto the
courtyard and are walled towards the streets.
New outward doors and windows are unlicensed -  illegal.
The city government sent workers to brick
them.
You need to be quick if you want to use them.
“The shop has helped us to make some money,
to improve our lives.
So of course we don’t like this
decision.
But what can we do?
If the government says so, we have to obey
- don’t we?”
Authorities have declined to comment on this
issue.
More than one thousand alleys are under threat.
Shop owners there stand to lose their livelihoods.
“For me it’s tough.
Im selling almost nothing recently.
I think I have no other choice than to go back
to my home province.”
For the moment, she and her neighbors do their best
to keep their shops open.
And finding creative ways to avoid
standing on a stool by a tiny window all day.